these baby white rhinos at a reserve in
South Africa have been perplexing the
internet and their scientists with their
high-pitched squeals I know what they've
done here they've got some rhinos and
then they've got some guy by the camera
going it's not real is Helen right
have we been Punk'd even though you
might not expect it these two white
rhino babies are actually making these
vocalizations in the wild baby rhinos
like these would be using these kinds of
signals to let their mom know that they
would like some milk rhinos will make
other sounds they'll grunt and pant
often in a very repetitive way and using
that technique they can communicate with
each other with remarkable precision
white rhinos have the most advanced
social system of all rhinos and because
they have poor eyesight it's thought
that sounds are very important for
communication and so even though these
babies probably only looking food at
this point they're exhibiting a behavior
which is gonna get more and more
developed as they grow